so what do you think's gonna happen in a
hundred years in new york where we're
just drinking water we're like oh
actually this [ __ ] is poisonous for us
it was our lead pipes we went to school
with [ __ ] asbestos all over the
garden absolutely so look how good we
turned out
no but we were why everybody's
[Laughter]
that is true though like i wonder if
like everybody was talking about how
wild new york was at certain points in
time like what if that was the case
what if we were just on some like
asbestos [ __ ] i mean it's still kind of
wild now
so they got to get some asbestos out the
bronx son like
god that's a good place right though
culvert is the new asbestos every city
[ __ ] up right now
new york is going crazy wait you think i
think so so it's a little it's a little
while all right i wanted to ask you
about this because like
i felt it
no i still kind of tapped it and this
[ __ ] is going really wow right now
and we're walking home and you're like
bro doesn't this [ __ ] feel crazy like it
feels like wild in new york i was like
oh shut up
i was like a little bit and he was like
yeah man anyway and then he just walks
and tries to get a cigarette from like
eight different people
he just walked into a homeless guy's
like you got a sick i was like you told
me to be careful he's like yeah be
careful
i'm just saying my head is more on a
swivel now and like yeah the difference
is another word like you hear can i tell
you can i tell you yeah you gotta head
on
just your neighbors like [ __ ]
that's the most you've got yeah the car
is coming from inside the house chelsea
wait
you acting like you don't live in long
island city right now
you got a fake balcony firecrackers
yo don't say cracker bro don't take crap
[ __ ] bro that's fine
they got a whole fireworks show right
along my water yes
gang [ __ ]
it's i think they just let the people
who are crazy out yes
yes
they're running amok
this is real don't agree with this is
real bro it's not gangs it's [ __ ]
crazy people like you what do you think
about getting letting them out of where
i see you with your colors finally out
there though
these guys
they used to wrangle these [ __ ]
up put them somewhere put them in the
hospital
nobody did it
crazy people have always been outside
okay
it's delta bro i'm telling you man
there's some crazies out there again
i've seen these dudes
i've seen two guys getting a fight with
money right it was the most
fight i ever seen in my entire life
there's a point where like new yorkers
get upset and everything just devolves
into suck my dick yeah right and
different ways to tell someone suck my
dick so the guy it was a dude who's
homeless another dude kind of homeless i
think he was trying to like rob the
other homeless dude [ __ ] and he's like
yo get the [ __ ] away from me i'm trying
to sleep get the [ __ ] away from me they
started talking [ __ ] and then suck my
dicks were just flying bro and it was so
entertaining i was walking the dog half
scared but also half like i got to see
where this goes he goes suck my dick he
goes he goes you know i'm gonna sleep on
the ground and i'm gonna go to your
mother's house so she could suck the
ground off my dick
[Music]
your mother your mother sucked my dick
your mother you won't kiss my dick
i got struck by a vehicle in my car
parked but i wasn't in it you're welcome
you're welcome no you needed to get rid
of that
downstairs i look at my car and the
whole front bumper is ripped off there's
no way new yorker hit it oh yeah you
haven't seen his car
yo can i be honest with you mark you
can't keep nothing nice bro no i got i'm
a victim also do you got the spare tire
on no they ripped the hubcap off no they
didn't yes and it's all just a top cap
on a car every car is a hubcap no it
don't oh your tesla doesn't have a
hubcap no it has a red rim you're stupid
do you have the plastic sticker
stupid you can't afford that but you
can't afford give me my phone back
are you serious
don't you ever talk about a scottish
prince against me this is
do you know how many pictures like that
he takes this [ __ ] i understand
how big his nipples are this is crazy
yeah lee
i have like a good ten pictures of him
just like that you know you don't take
pics while you're laying out keep my
phone man
no no i keep going through that [ __ ]
those two
no that's
that's weird yeah that's mr 49 right
there was it 49 or 47. you guys aren't
european at all like me that's the
problem new york is the most homophobic
the second they get in the fight it suck
my big man yeah
but
that's how homophobic
bro
that [ __ ] was crazy you might take
someone up on that if they say that just
just to prove a point suck my dick okay
okay
bring it out joey
all right